[Music]
who are some of your main competitors
going into this event and who do we
enjoy playing against the most the owner
onion always plays well in repeating
breeds so his kind of very dangerous
most worthless or just just showed a
brilliant performance so the question is
if he would keep his form to this
tournament or not but anyway I will try
to concentrate on my own cheese Fabiana
I got the one who the one is in very
good form the last couple of months
others I'm not a competitor to anybody
here in your so ok the task is not to
lose all 27 games and not to be driven
insane after this number of games
against opponents I think the main race
for the qualification is going to be
between me Anand and Wesley because
we're very close to each other with the
points so yeah I of course I have to
watch out for other players as well
everybody's so strong but the main goal
is to be ahead of them all players is
interesting mmm but I not play with
Karin an example and okay it's very
interesting because he can get eight on
one title of world champion I think that
everyone is main competitor it's not
like anyone here is it's going to be an
easy game there are two players why I
don't have much experience with horrible
I played him I think last time in 2012
and it was classical not a rapido blitz
and I don't think I've ever played a
game against Artemyev besides like
online blitz casually
never a serious form again so those are
two players who are pretty new to me and
the rest of the players I've played very
open I I don't really have a good score
against kayaking
and an Iranian so that's something I
have to work on the other players I've
seen will sound awesome so of course all
of them are really really strong and
anyone can win this tournament depending
on their the ship main rivals right now
the three of us who have two events left
and are within one point of each other
LaVon and Leslie and me I'd like to
finish ahead of them for obvious reasons
and try to avoid the mistake of focusing
too much on these guys did you let other
one slip and I'll try to remember that
the only thing and counts is the number
of points at the end of the tournament
but you know I think we will be all
looking back and forth